غضب متصاعد في الشارع البريطاني وتنسيق
باد بين النقابات لتصاعد الضغوط على
الحكومه مئات الالاف اضربه مدرسون واساتذه
جامعات وموظفون عموميون وحكوميون وسائقوا
قطارات وغيرهم اغلب المدارس اغلقت اما
كليا او جزئيا وشبكه القطارات شلت بشكل
شبه تام وكذلك اكثر من مئه مرفق حكومي
شيء ومسيره وتظاهره حاشده على باب الحكومه
انه لا يمكنها الاستمرار في التجاهل هذه
المشكله وان محاولاتهم لحلها عبر
التشريعات جديده
في رواتبهم لكنها لا تقول انها اخذت هذه
الاموال من مخصصات الاطفال في ميزانها
يطالب المطربون بزياده رواتبهم لتناسب
معدلات التضخم وتلك بلغت اعلى مراتبها في
اكثر من اربعين عاما لكن الحكومه ثابته
على موقفها
عندما يتعلق الامر بالمعلمين فقد اعطيناهم
اعلى زياده في الاجور منذ 30 عاما تعليم
اطفالنا ثمين للغايه وهم يستحقون ان
يكونوا في المدرسه اليوم يتعلموا يجب ان
تخرج المعارضه وتقول ان الاضرابات خطا وان
علينا ان ندعمه اطفالنا في المدارس
تقول الحكومه انها التزمت بتوصيات هيئات
مراجعه الاجور المستقله في تقدير زيادات
الاجور لكن هذا اقل بكثير مما تطلبه
النقابات المعركه مستمره اذن ومجلس
النقابات المهنيه الذي يجمع تحت مظلته
عشرات النقابات بات مشاركا فيها
اكبر من نوعه في بريطانيا منذ اكثر من 10
سنوات لكن الاهم فيه ان الدخول مجلس
النقابات المهنيه على خط المواجهه المباشر
مع الحكومه ينقل تلك المواجهه الى مرحله
جديده مرحله قد تكون سمعتها الابرز
التصعيد اسد الله الصاوي الجزيره لندن